today we had a few items quite important
on our agenda we started by presenting
the priorities of creation presidency
later on Commission also presented three
new documents with a V European semester
and we had two topics which took quite I
would say constructive and Tauro
dialogue discussion one on the European
Grid deal with specific focus on
European Green Deal investment plan and
the last topic was our continuation of a
debate and discussion on the topic of
taxation with specific emphasis of
digital taxation today we heard a strong
support and commitments from finance
ministers to take ownership of the green
transition we share the views that each
country has its own challenges and
different starting points and the
Commission takes these different points
into account in its work it is also
clear that private capital will how to
cover the biggest part of transition
costs this is why one of my top
priorities is to drive forward our
sustainable finance agenda and bring
private investors on board ministers
also stressed the necessity for
international cooperation in this field
because EU is not the biggest polluter
this is why we already launched
international platform for sustainable
finance to work with other countries and
greening as a global financial system
and we are now reaching out for more
countries to join
moving to the digital taxation we are
heading now for a crucial moment of
reform of international corporate tax
system we have seen some progress as
oacd
on the first strand of reforms also
called a pillar one but we need to make
sure that these reforms are meaningful
when businesses are active in
jurisdictions without physical presence
this activity has to be captured
effectively we're more concerned at the
lack of parallel progress on minimum
effective taxation measures or pillar
two this is fundamental ensuring that
all businesses pay a fair share of tax
so today we called in you finance
ministers to speak with one voice
internationally on this you must be
active in the design of the global
solution to make sure among other things
that it worked for us both in terms of
fairness and competitiveness on a 10th
of January your country should all how
transpose the fifths anti-money
laundering directive these are wider
rules to ensure the integrity of the
Union financial system but I'm concerned
that quite a few of member states shall
not transpose them yet and there are no
two ways about it these rules must be
implemented in full and in timely way so
we will not be sitting idle here our
proposed to initiate infringement
proceedings against countries lagging
behind as early as in February